[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt wo
ich stehe heute nicht allein in der
küche dass es nicht morath sonderdienste
delhi und die seele hat mich eingeladen
heute mal mit ihr einen einen kuchen zu
backen
die frage ist komisch und zwar gut da
aus österreich genau auf salzburg und
zwar habe den ddv kurzer zeit in
österreich kennengelernt wir waren da im
europark in salzburg
und er hat es da am zwei richtig kohle
leben einmal der bäckerei
das ist unten und oben gibt es noch das
restaurant delicious richtig lecker und
ich muss sagen wir haben zwei tage
richtig gut gegessen
ja also sowohl mittags zum kaffee und
tee als auch abends dann zum abendessen
zwar alles celica sie war richtig super
wenn die hatten natürlich gut gefallen
ja die kinder hatten das boot war so
genial ist also coolen austausch immer
mal wieder das heißt wir gehen nach
salzburg sowie sind also sagen hier
hielten die türken die nach wien
gekommen
danach haben sie gesagt haben kommt hier
nicht rein erstmals zurück aber der digi
wird mich immer wieder mit nach sei
nicht geschafft und heute haben wir eine
richtig coole torte gemeinsam gehen also
wir backen die jetzt gleich und zwar ist
das eine passion sports ist
passionsfrucht chili dann haben wir noch
unsere macht dann ein bisschen mehr
gelder ist eben unsere weiße schokolade
und ganz darunter hammer dann noch
mitgemacht ich nicht so wolltest dienen
drin ist noch eine überraschung mit der
preis aber die zeigen wir euch gleich
denn wir starten jetzt zuerst mal mit
dem weg da machen in 123 map zeigt also
ein teil zucker zwei teile butter und
drei teile mit und da geht ganz fix und
hier vorne stehen auch schon mal die
zutaten für den 123 mit brauche ich 50
gramm puderzucker 100 gramm kalte butter
und 150 gramm mehl also normalerweise
mache ich mich immer mit der maschine
geht einfacher aber ich würde sagen
jetzt habe ich denn die da
dann darfst du das jetzt machen dass du
mich ein bisschen quälen ja sogar ja
wenn der dicke ist die maschine richtig
in der natur und ich bin markt sowie hat
wenn es dich nicht vor ort arbeiten
nachhaltig ja so ist es siehst du nur
ein richtiger mann knetet den wechsel
war genau die macht auch richtig ist hat
er der dpa ich habe das schon mal gesagt
der tdi ist der florian silbereisen der
branche
januar christian teppe mir studentenfilm
twins mit einer schwarzen jacke und ich
war die nachricht das macht ja auch spaß
der teig teig zu kneten und weißt du
warum ich gemacht und gerade bei
mürbeteig wenn du dir zu weich wird
kannst du dir aus und somit den hinten
habe ich richtig das gefühl danach
richtig gut ist steiner zwar aus und es
ist halt wichtig dass man mir beträgt
nicht so lange kneten auch dass er nicht
so weit wird und du hast ja nicht in der
bäckerei und salzburg ja es ist ein café
der bagel bakery genau investor das
heißt die delicious ja das ist meine
frau eingefangen und dem delicious ja
das ist in salzburg geben europas meist
so lecker dass sie nicht europa park
sagt er
in deutschland kann in deutschland ja
wie gesagt und da war ja auch schon beim
den er und sein lecker ja auch der teig
sieht super aus doch mal da komme ich
schon mal so als hätte ich hier gerade
mitgearbeitet 48 aber echt ein schöner
tag
wenn du jetzt lust könntest du wieder
ein bisschen vanille dazu genau könnte
man ja noch dazu gegeben
bestimmt nicht also den tag legt ist
hier ein denken ach und dann kümmerte
ihn ja schon mal kühl für eine halbe
stunde
und in der zwischenzeit machen wir den
maracuja saft oder super für den
passionsfrucht brauchen wir jetzt den
passus früchte
100 milliliter wasser 50 gramm zucker
und eine reife mango eigentlich sollte
ich ja die mango schälen aber du hast
gesagt du weißt ein super super trick wo
ich keine schilder braucht genau aus
eigentlich sehen ist kein fehler drin
ist jetzt einfach die mango und da ist
ein großer kern in der mitte und da kann
man einmal drumrum schneiden hier ist
der kern
hier rechts noch mal drum herum
schneiden und jetzt nimmst du einfach
ein hohes klar okay und kannst es so
daran stücken von praktisch die haut so
einfach wegziehen
supercool gepresst ist so am glas
entlang und gar kein verlust nicht gar
kein verlust ganz schön wegschneiden
schaue hat sich gelohnt haben und dann
schneide ich das gleiche dürfen ja ok
sag mal du was nicht mal mit dem
persönlichen bereich unsere
passionsfrucht und da ist wirklich so am
besten zeig ich dir das mal dass ich mir
ganz ernst richtig süß etwas falsch ist
aber auch etwas mehr peter auffallend
für uns okay wenn diese haben wir ja
durch die man genau ist und daher
partner und werden euch die sonst zu
sauer ist 23 tage einfach heraus
entstehen lassen dann werden die genauso
schon beginnen
ich dachte ja als kind immer dass die
dann schlecht sind ja aber mittlerweile
weiß ich sie werden dann immer besser
und hier in deutschland wird oft
passionsfrucht und maracuja für die
gleiche frucht beim verwendet aber es
hat eine kleine unterschied ist es zwar
die gleiche art aber eine
unterschiedliche sorte aber keine beide
für alles benutzen
beide haben gleich verwendet so die du
jetzt gleich wie auch zum auslöffeln dem
ausleger und richtig mit den canon alles
wieder so schnell ist dabei die mango
dann gehen wir noch unser wasser und den
zucker oder zu kochen und dann kann man
schöne sache
[Musik]
darf ich die mango zur faser zu geben
dann gehen wir gleich und sebastian noch
die ja also ich benutzt hier er denn
wirklich maracuja wir sagt er passiert
es braucht geld und wahrscheinlich
zucker nach geschmack oder ja ich glaube
die harmonisierung er damit noch dazu
geben dann kann ich ja weniger komplett
lassen
das ganze gucken jetzt circa fünf
minuten und dann durch bisschen aber es
klar und ich schreibe auch sein
danke du darfst abtrocknen der möglich
ist jetzt gut abgekühlt und den rolle
ich jetzt direkt auf der back folie aus
denn dann muss man nicht noch mal hoch
nehmen und genau effect 2 ja zu zweit
praxis besser und den brauchen wir jetzt
auch etwa 24 cm wie ich das dann meist
machen damit ich nichts übrig habe ich
habe jetzt war kriegen schon mal
eingestellt
ok und dann kann man da drauf setzen und
die reste einfach noch rein drücken
aber wenn man doch erste hat macht man
einfach noch ein paar kekse dazu
[Musik]
so ging's superschnell und damit er beim
backen schon flach bleibt da stecken wir
ihn einfach mehrmals mit einer gabel ein
und dann kann er schon den ofen
du mir jetzt circa 10 minuten bei 170
grad ober unterhitze ist eigentlich
schön goldpreis super also unserer
website ist perfekt da ist richtig schön
goldbraun den haben wir jetzt auch die
terrasse gestellt damit er abkühlen kann
und jetzt kommt die show genau dieser
schoko muss das ja richtig erste schicht
nachmittag richtig lecker und hier vorne
haben ja schon mal die zutaten ich
stelle sie aber kurz vor für die weiße
schokoladen mousse brauchen wir ein
eigelb dreimal blatt gelatine
ich habe mir 150 gramm weiße schokolade
250 gramm sahne und nochmal drei
esslöffel sahne okay was war zuerst
machen ich würde einfach mal sagen die
weiße schokolade die aber schon fein
gehackt und hier hatte ich gerade eben
wasser aufgekocht und das können wir
hier schmelzen lassen weiß schokolade
braucht nicht so viel hitze genau
bescheid schlag man sich eigentlich
seine tochter mit dem auf da gehen wir
jetzt hier trennen und das eiweiß heben
war auch für später angehen und das
braucht man dann für die zweite schicht
unsere version braucht ja lecker ein
eigelb ein ganzes ein
genau das tun wir dann wieder über dem
wasserbad waren aufschlagen angehen
lassen was hat es denn mit dem wander
holen auftritt da steht ja vom wandern
ja da ist ein bauer in österreich her
gegangen daher eigentlich kein bauernhof
software hat sondern hat gesagt der
hühnerstall vater mit seinem traktor in
den hühnerstall auf seinen traktor ja
die hühner alle rennen und jeden tag
geht eigentlich auf eine andere wie sehr
lässt seine hühner raus und am abend
sind sie wieder drinnen und darum sind
das die wander und die wandern ja
tatsächlich ja kein werbegag ich sehe
ich wirklich so ja ach die haben wir ein
schönes leben ja sehr schön da schmeckt
unsere tochter später bestimmt umso
besser
das richtig gut was habe ich dir geben
nicht schneebesen sehr schön ich habe
jetzt noch einen kleinen
ich war jetzt wieder den vergleich nur
beim auto und ich habe jetzt hier die
klatschmagazine damit die rinder
verabschiedet und die kümmert hier in
kaltem wasser einweichen
und lassen jetzt einfach so 45 minuten
genau ausgerechnet dass man es dann gut
ausdrücken kann ja und dann du mal eben
diese stammt was wir da haben anschlag
kommt dann standen genau also die drei
esslöffel sahne und da gehen wir dann
die stellen
auf einmal war ich nervös und ich kenne
das schon mal einen satz zwischenzeit
die sahne auf schlag und mein doktor ist
eigentlich auch schon war das bislang
machen müssen genau hierzu auch schon
okay und wie lange er soll man das dann
rühren wirst du mit ganz lustig
aufschlagen ganz weise ein bisschen weil
ich ja genommen ganz weiß creme ist auch
wieder da
[Musik]
also meine sahnesteif die gelatine ist
eingereicht die sahne haben wir erwärmt
wenn man auch gekauft wird viel zu
fahrig den herd aus und dann muss man
sich einfach in der pause raus haben
aber ich kenne das meine erste ich aber
viele zuschauer in österreich oder die
schreibt noch immer schlagobers kenne
ich und chieming ist die sahne mit der
gelatine schön langsam richtig gut
gebildet und im prinzip kann man die
muss ja auch mit acker machen also mit
platin aber die wird halt immer so ein
bisschen kompakter die wird halt nicht
ganz fertig aber geht auf jeden fall
super gute bio schilling
ich denke das ist auch alles gut
verrühren jetzt langsam die weiße
schokolade mit dazu
so jetzt unser headquarter kriegen ist
eigentlich fertig wir füllen jetzt um
weil einfach die schüssel noch zu warm
erst wegen der sahne und man sieht oft
wenn du richtig gut da nimmst ja ja ja
das kann ich mir auch eine andere fahrer
ist dieser motor ist unter bei uns in
deutschland heißt dass die aua hat die
vista ist der dümmste bauer hat die
größten kartoffeln
du bist noch nicht im raum ach so ja
[Gelächter]
magath super der us konsum soll wenn man
schmittmann das hätte ich dies jetzt
unsere green droht also der map guide
ist komplett abgehört
dies ist hey nein das ist unsere jetzt
gehen wir unsere mannes steht getroffen
jetzt sie einfach so rein geschrieben
wachstums leber oder frau zuliebe noch
liebe durchgängig kochen
das habe ich mich am liebsten machen
also nicht isst am liebsten das habe ich
mir auf und du da finde ich sogar kohle
so die passen nicht mehr rein dem effeff
wirkt genau so jetzt kann man die torte
ablenkung genau und will stellen
und dann kommt schon unsere nächste
schicht die passionsfrucht sei lecker
dass in der zwischenzeit wird aufgeräumt
so jetzt immer glaube ich soweit gern
sieht man dann immer auch schön wenn die
mango richtig wissen dass dies
vielleicht wird okay ich hab sogar schon
probiert es ist sehr schön säuerlich und
schmeckt richtig gut also ich glaube mit
der weißen musters später richtig lecker
ok jetzt einmal durch passieren wegen
den kernen wichtig ich muss sagen mich
stören sie gar nicht so sehr aber in der
torte gemacht aber schon eine riesen
sauerei grad gut möchte ist vielleicht
auch die terrasse machen schickst du
mich weg aus der küche mit peter sauber
machen also während der tt dass da
draußen macht warte ich einfach und
macht hier die sauerei noch schnell weg
[Musik]
oh mein gott die idee wie sieht es hier
aus wie ich weiß aber es lohnt sich
assange will man das jetzt machen die
die ich nehme jetzt den saft mit nach
drinnen und bringt ihren ganzen schrank
anzubieten und renate steht schon seit
etwa 30 minuten im kühlschrank ist auch
ganz wichtig damit einfach die masse
fest wird jetzt kommt die passionsfrucht
muss den saft haben wir schon gemacht da
ist schon abgekühlt ist richtig gut vor
allem haben wir die weiße schokolade
dieser richtig süß dann die säure aus
der passionsfrucht mega lecker ich zeige
euch mal ganz kurz vorne die zutaten für
die passionsfrucht muss brauche ich 150
milliliter vom selbstgemachten saft ein
eiweiß vier blätter gelatine 30 gramm
zucker 3 esslöffel sahne und 125
milliliter sahne so ich glaube ich darf
der eiweiß und zucker geben genau ich
beginne wieder gleich es vorher dass ich
sage eiweiß und zucker durch wir über
einem wasserbad bahnhofstraße super und
ich kann schon mal die blätter gelatine
einfach in kaltem wasser einweichen
ein paar minuten und kann in der
zwischenzeit schon mal die sahne steif
schlagen
[Musik]
bei mir ist david steindor ist die
restliche sahne genommen genau hier
konnten wasserhaus dann die sahne kinder
kurz aufkochen übermäßig wichtiges
platine nur immer dass man sie nicht auf
kocht gehen auch etwas hinterher
komplett anders als für gaga das muss
man extra lange kochen aber relative auf
keinen fall das einfach sagen etwas
aufbauen um herbst sehen und sich die
zähne ausbissen
[Musik]
also die idee ich glaube der schnee ist
fertig der sitzt ziemlich gut aus also
schön weiß cremig und auch schon
abgekühlt
und jetzt kann mitbestimmen die gelatine
rein und danach kommt der saft rein
[Musik]
wenn du machst das so gut ich gebe dir
einfach die steif geschlagene sahne und
dann geht das soll mir einer sagen küche
könne nicht was lernen unsere dort
wartet dann holistic hast es ist immer
schön wenn man die frauen schicken kann
hallo das habe ich gerne mein
kühlschrank steht im gleichen raum
[Musik]
also ich habe zu den tortenring gut fest
teils einfach so den luftblasen raus und
jetzt kommen die torte nochmal im
kühlschrank noch mal für etwa eine halbe
stunde mindestens bis die schicht fest
ist und dann kommt noch die dritte
schicht trauer
dann haben wir einem wirklich lecker
also das gleich jetzt kommt die letzte
schicht auf die torte wir haben jetzt
hier nochmal 300 milliliter von unserem
selbstgemachten jetzt kannst du in
dörfern so ungefähr 100 milliliter eben
einen topf und hier haben wir doch mal
für blätter gelatine in kaltem wasser
aufgelöst eingeweicht das wird es
ausgedrückt ist nämlich schon weiß
das tun wir dazu gerne und bin jetzt
auch nicht den ganzen tag weil ansonsten
wäre der ganze sagt waren und wir müssen
wieder ewig lange warten bis abkühlt
also nur einen teil kurz aufkochen
lassen
dann die gelatine mit dazu und auflösen
und während du willst ich kenne den
herrn jetzt aus machen damit ich nicht
auftaucht während größte ruhig schon mal
die torte aber die schönen dinge mit
passionsfrucht hat sich aufgelöst und
dass geht mir jetzt alles wieder zurück
verwöhnt das ganze noch mal hat die
deutsche schon damals ein luftbläschen
aber das ist es nicht schlimm so dann
darf ich schon mal drüber und es macht
auch überhaupt nicht gerne noch ein paar
körner drin war kennt wenn sie macht gar
nichts das sieht jeder ist hausgemacht
und parken haben wir noch draußen auf
der terrasse ja nicht dass man später so
ein maracuja baum wächst jetzt kommt die
tochter noch mal in den kühlschrank also
ich würd sagen insgesamt sollte sie so
etwa vier stunden mindestens durch
kühlen wir stellen jetzt noch mal für
etwa eine stunde in den kühlschrank und
danken wir schon probieren
[Musik]
die tat ist fertig wir haben sie auf dem
bergring rausgenommen und opfer die
sieht so gut aus sie sieht eigentlich so
richtig perfekt aus muss ich sagen
und im innern kann man diese männer
schnitten ja ok bester immer ganz anders
kommen ist das erste stück haben und bin
ich nicht wir haben größte könig so
probieren
ok ja genau machst du das ja ja das ist
richtig weil sie vielleicht in
deutschland noch nicht so gut aus aber
ich bin wahrscheinlich der größte
restaurant nach nachher ein kein motor
einer karotte und möchte sie in den
branchen der österreicher hat ungefähr
deine figur macht es war böse die die du
darfst jederzeit wiederkommen es war
sehr lustig und ich lade ich natürlich
auch ein zu mehr mitgehen bald fischen
moran soll jetzt mal über was aus ja ich
sag jetzt mal ehrlich das schmeckt ja
hier aber es könnte höchstens vielleicht
nicht aber in deutschland kennst du
hältst du split bis eis ja das hat er
außen so orange und edelweiß ist in
österreich aus schlitz kennst du das
meinst du kannst du erst mal zeigen
zeigt er unterschritt genau das
reichliche spricht die flecker rücken
her nicht zu süß nicht gleich vier
säulen drin ich klasse was meinen sie
denn zu den schnitte leben drin
ja du bist kippstangen richtig richtig
und ich finde auch wenn es galt werbung
gar nicht probiert
dennoch version an den start und ich
will in österreich auch mal fischen geht
hinaus war nach filz muss das ist ein
fußballer bischofs mit reaktionen
richtig schönes bergmassiv und darm ein
gebirgsbach und da gehen wir fischen
unter mamas liebling
also ich bin auch meine schwiegereltern
immer wieder dass fast alleine aus halo
das hinkriegen unglaublich so kam eine
stütze meinen eltern
warstein die schwiegereltern hören ja
die reden mit mama kocht hier nichts
mehr ja erst mal kennen jeden fall ist
die torte super lecker
falls ihr das rezept gerne nachmachen
möchte dann schaut auf meinem blog
vorbei ab seliges blog daily danke für
das richtig coole rezept ich denke und
ich freue mich schon auf die nächste
konzepte und wir kommen auch mal zu den
nach österreich bringen auch rezepte mit
jedenfalls hat sehr viel spaß gemacht
hat war lustig oder leben die waffen ja
also ich noch viel spaß beim nachbacken
und wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal dann
habe ich von unseren cool fotoshooting
erzählt
das war richtig cool denn da haben wir
einen acres torte gebacken
das rezept gibt es ja auch dem kanal von
interspar da könnte auch auf jeden fall
mal vorbeischauen da lernt die richtig
gute vanillecreme oh ja da meine
italienische buttercreme gemeint
hausgemachte marmelade richtig gut also
die ist richtig lecker wie willst du auf
jeden fall probieren und das video
findet ihr verlinkt einfach hier genau
also freunde die österreicher liebe
deutsche eingeführten und alle anderen
auch sehen uns zunächst einmal gut
gehört jetzt mir ich kann schon mal
ehrlich ich nehme auch den kuchen ja
macht
[Musik]
[Applaus]